[Applause]
it's so great to do to see you like how
is your family
good good good my dad's doing okay you
know we're post surgery for his post
pancreatic cancer so it's a really long
journey this year but you know now it's
just trying to get some weight on him
and my daughter just turned 17 like
doing all this like diet stuff and like
workout stuff and mindfulness stuff so
she's just like my mom is super healthy
right now like you know I guess just
going into 2020 strong get it mom's yeah
life is you know just grateful yeah I'm
trailing a little behind her but I'm
trying to but you adopted actually
you're 17 you adopted her when she was
12 but she moved when she was 11 yeah oh
and eleven that's it so why did you
choose to adopt we talked about this a
lot on the show actually and I was
talking about sistent about this poor
she's adopted can chew his fills sorry
because a lot of the older kids never
get adopted it towards the babies so it
was that a that was a strong choice for
you guys I told my mom when I was five
years old that I was going to adopt and
I was gonna adopt older because that was
when I found out that my dad is not my
biological father yeah and he you know
married my mom when she was 18 years old
with a one-year-old yeah and raised me
as his own that's why I'm a Dawson and
you know when I figured that out and
found that I just said Wow like what
would that have been like I have so many
friends who are single you know have
single parent yeah and you know what if
I was five now or six now would someone
have wanted to adopt me then so I was
like you know what I'm going to when I
get older I'm gonna adopt
changes like it's almost like once kids
hit five and above it just changes your
percentage of like getting adopted goes
just wait it yeah and you were actually
a part of a documentary about
homelessness right like with you
homelessness yeah it's called lost in
America and you know it's for a lot of
girls you know like my daughter would
have more than likely statistically aged
out and more than likely become homeless
statistically because you don't have a
network you have no community around you
no life skills that you know life skills
are just like you know ever you know
keep the fall back you know that just
that those that the family that's coming
together and rallying to your aid to
kind of grow and develop and so there's
a story about that at a girl who ends up
in foster care attends up homeless and
the homelessness problem that you were
seeing is just growing all across this
country is a very serious thing and when
people talk about you know real housing
that's a that's that could be a real
real real benefit to society and I
exactly Bennett if people act like it's
been a process so much yeah actually
it's costing us way more not to take
care of each other yeah a hundred
percent we've actually worked with a lot
of that on the show like especially with
youth and homelessness and it's like
people don't get like didn't choose that
they were born into this situation like
nobody wakes up when dingos can't wait
to sleep in a tent like outside of a
building like nobody does that and these
kids matter everybody matters no matter
where you're from and I thought it was
really beautiful but I do want to talk
about your new show as well you just
drinking a beer in that shot is way
cooler than me on any day you just exude
cool I'm just gonna let it out now but
what's your new show briar patch about
well my character is suddenly given the
news that her sisters died um she is a
police officer and died in a car bomb so
she goes back to her hometown to
investigate her sister's murder and it
just gets crazier and more wild and
weirder than that she also works for in
a Senate subcommittee so she works for a
senator who she's you know in having a
situation with maybe relations relations
is that way
research it was research no you are very
method that's all I'm saying
[Applause]
I think he's so awesome I think it's
very telling of your character too don't
want a man like that they're so strong
and so infinite knows what he wants and
those what's good for people was a cool
dude he is a really great very cool but
it was also research too as we did we
shot the pilot for the show in September
of two thousand eighteen and then Cory
and I started dating in October of 2018
and I remember when the show got picked
up and we started doing ADR and we were
gonna film the rest of it last year I
talked to the showrunner Andy and I was
like so art imitates life or in life
imitates art I think I have the answer
to that fine it's so crazy oh yeah it's
a cool show yeah luckily you know when
you watch the show it's definitely more
cynical version of looking at politics
and looking at sort of the world in
general or not but yeah that's not the
case with Cory thank goodness I know no
he seems really cool but speaking of
running for office there's a game on the
web right now to figure out your
personal presidential campaign slogan I
love it it's your name the year you want
to run for president and the last thing
you texted so I feel like it works mine
and I figured this out before the show
and it's awesome - Clarkson 20:28 oh
shoot you actually just reminded me that
Cassie texted me and I never got back to
her I'm such an ass please tell her I'm
so sorry I just remembered grimace face
what is yours
I was like beforehand I was like I
cannot believe this is my last actually
I just I texted cab because I was
actually sending him the first two
episodes that's you know he gets extra
first so I just went just for you baby
like Dawson
20:28 just for you baby and Rihanna was
performing and then like the surprise
guest was Kanye West yeah and he came
out and everyone got super excited to
see him and the first thing he walks up
to the mic with all this like rounding
applause and the first thing he says is
you're welcome and I was like he's
talking about running for office and I
think that should be his campaign
you're welcome he West's for president
actually you're welcome I actually say
that a lot myself so I can't make you're
welcome but it's messed up I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this